hey crazies we saw in the last video the
white dwarves are pretty awesome
they're the leftover core of a low-mass
star like our Sun shrunk to the size of
a planet or moon but we can get even
smaller than those white dwarves white
dwarves white dwarves white dwarves the
next group of stellar corpses are
neutron stars let's do this as you can
see from this chart the original star
that makes a neutron star needs to have
at least eight times the mass of our Sun
anything less and it will only make a
white dwarf anything more than 20 and it
becomes a black hole neutron stars are
the sweet spot in between how come an
eight solar mass star doesn't make an
eight solar mass neutron star because
the whole star doesn't become a neutron
star just its core a star's core is
where the fusion is happening but that
core is surrounded by several other
layers that are just hot those outer
layers are where you'll find the
majority of a star's mass but those
layers get blasted away during the
star's death throes only the core is
left behind to collapse into a stellar
course so an eight solar mass star only
makes a one point four solar mass corpse
and a twenty solar mass star only makes
a three solar mass corpse a neutron star
is exactly what it sounds like a star
made of neutrons you know those little
particles you usually find in an atomic
nucleus except the whole stars made of
neutrons well almost
how is that even possible because
gravity's a thing that leftover core is
heavy so it collapses under its own
gravity which speeds up the particles
inside mostly the electrons the faster
they're going the more kinetic energy
they have if the core collapses enough
the total energy of the electrons will
make up for the mass difference between
the protons and neutrons at that point
the protons will react with the
electrons and become neutrons this
inverse beta decay as it's called
happens through most of the collapsing
core after the stars millions or
billions of years of life this last
process is very violent and very fast
in a matter of hours today's the extreme
temperatures released gamma rays that
smash larger nuclei like iron into
smaller nuclei like helium the inverse
beta decay turns protons into neutrons
releasing a flood of neutrinos into
space that core will continue to
collapse until something stops it Q the
Pauli exclusion principle that principle
doesn't just apply to electrons it
applies to all fermions neutrons are
also spin 1/2 particles they're fermions
too but because they're neutral they can
get a lot closer together they reach
densities comparable to atomic nuclei
before they stop collapsing unlike the
white dwarf which is the size of a
planet or moon a neutron star would be
the size of a small city is it true that
a teaspoon of it would weigh as much as
a mountain not exactly okay so a
teaspoon of neutron star matter also
known as neutronium what happened the
mass of a small mountain but mass and
weight are not the same thing on the
surface of a neutron star it's going to
weigh a lot more than a mountain because
a neutron stars gravity is much stronger
than Earth's a trillion times stronger
but what if we scooped it up and brought
it to explore the only thing keeping
that neutronium stable is the gravity of
the neutron star you won't get that
teaspoon very far before most of it
decayed back into protons and electrons
releasing unimaginable amounts of
radiation very quickly you did plus if
you're scooping that matter from the
outside of the neutron star you're
probably not getting just neutrons the
electrons on the outside of the collapse
weren't moving fast enough to make more
neutrons so that stuff still behaves
more like white dwarf matter this also
explains how it's possible for a neutron
star to have a magnetic field
remember magnetic fields require charge
neutral things can't make them
thankfully neutron stars have some
protons and electrons left over on the
outer edges those particles are the
source of a neutron stars very strong
magnetic field but that field doesn't
necessarily line up with the Stars
rotation at the North and South Poles
you'll find outward jets of charged
particles and since those charges are
accelerated they produce light that
beams into space
light that could be anywhere on the
spectrum from radio waves to gamma rays
this creates a kind of light house
effect and if things line up just right
we can receive a regular pulse here on
earth if that's the case we call it a
pulsar which is just short for pulsing
star and these things spin fast
so the pulses are more like this or even
faster this used to be the only way we
could discover them but now with Lego we
can detect more of them by their
gravitational waves especially when they
hit each other like this Oh was that
four on top of that because of
gravitational warping neutron stars
would look really weird up close you
could actually see part of its back when
looking at the front these things are
weird
so got any other questions about neutron
stars ask in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
speaking of patreon support at any level
now gets you exclusive access to video
bloopers in fact I just uploaded a new
one if you're pledging you should go
check it out and thanks for watching
[Music]